Gamescom in germany a press conference
yes they showed battlefield hardline
it's the first footage that we've seen
since the delay
they showed 12 minutes of single-player
yes it was kind of funny that
single-player had a lot of elements from
other games in it for example it have
like a Far Cry 3
tagging system it had an intimidation
that made people surrender thing from
like payday 2 had a fake surrender from
hitman absolution and also a lot of the
the layout of the map and like the
movement of the player through the
environment was also to me very similar
to Splinter Cell yeah like I had that
sort of stealth mechanic with a little
bit of a choose-your-own-adventure
approach to it which they even joked
about the beginning like right before
they go and he's like hey we can go left
but we can go right yeah or we could
take them head-on
if you rope for that thank you lead
actually I was kind of at least happy
that they didn't like pop up on screen
with those three options let's click on
one you know it's like no just still go
ahead yeah just give it a hint but not
like told do do this exactly you know
like a little bit of player freedom
there Nick mendosa
right the antagonist in this 12-minute
demo was like right-wing extremists yes
that may or may not go for a while a
sort of clive in bundy theme in the so i
will say like people who like
battlefield tend to probably also like
firearms and people who certain
percentage people like firearms are
probably also you know would consider
themselves conservative or right-wing
so it's a risky move salted demographic
okay so they also showed some new
multiplayer yes to new multiplayer modes
Hotwire and Rescue yes that's in
addition to the ones that we saw in the
beta which were heist and Blood Money so
I'm really excited about hot wire
because heist never produced the car
chases that I really want her in the
family and we had that leaked hardline
trailer that seemed to be highlighting
that sort of vehicle movement side of
the game and yeah the beta wasn't
showcasing that more or less unique
feature to the battlefield experience
and the cars really supported it and it
seemed like they were trying to go after
what
Tactical Intervention yes you do and it
was really cool but it was just too
janky to actually work yeah cool idea
just not well executed so I'm very
excited to have a car-chase mood the
other one was their rescue mode which
they said was eSports designed but
basically it's just the hostage rescue
mode from counter-strike right and which
also reminds us of the Rainbow six game
that's coming up as well yeah very
competitive or like could potentially
compete with Rainbow six siege yeah so
you know again it's like the theme of
this was it feels like they pulled in a
lot of elements from a lot of your other
favorite games right and that's the
thing I I'm actually kind of excited
about these modes like they do show that
they're willing to try something
different for battlefield and I know
that from the battlefield community
that's gonna be met with sort of mixed
emotions you know like even for me
watching this stuff I'm like yeah it
looks kind of cool but it's not
battlefield but it does look kind of
cool like it does look like it could be
a very you know at least polished and
well designed game without having to be
true to the franchise's art and I'm
completely okay with that if you're
gonna make an off-brand battlefield you
might as well make it like pretty
different yeah and you like you let's be
honest like that'll feel for is somewhat
stale after battlefield 3 it was you
know it's kind of a got 3.5 yeah so
having a little bit of a fresh take and
I have to admit I'm somewhat confident
about the look of this single-player I
mean I didn't even click campaign on
battlefield 4 and I only maybe got
halfway through three I mean I don't I
feel like they were not making very
compelling characters or story the way
like maybe bat company did and so I was
just ready to say forget about
single-player altogether but this
single-player content actually looks a
little bit more interesting the only
funny thing I saw in this I will point
out is in the rescue mode the dude was
carrying the hostage like Ace Ventura
man scarf style
which is cool cos he had his life Baliga
yeah he had his he had a secondary out
whatever it's that's trivial the only
thing that bothered me a little bit was
that despite the really kind of
cool-looking mechanics that we were
seeing that there what still wasn't like
a dedication to realism of like as soon
as like you got past some of the stealth
mechanic or some of the marking
mechanics all of a sudden you're in a
gunfight and you know the destruction is
kind of cool the effects are kind of
cool but like the guy is standing
straight up in front of the enemy
getting shot and returning fire and like
these moments where all of a sudden it
departs from a sense of realism and it
popped me out a little bit watching the
footage that way especially like in the
single-player there was getting cool
mechanic of telling people to freeze and
like put up you know put their hands up
but like in the context of that moment
where you're assaulting a compound with
like 30 enemies like two guys or Milko
there's this dude here who is telling us
to put our weapons down I guess we'll do
that you know doesn't mean it's not
gonna be fun the one thing I will say is
in those gunfights I did notice that
they were using the same mechanics as
multiplayer such as the grappling hook
and the the player didn't seem be able
to take a lot of damage so it's good
like a good single-player campaign
should always train people for the
multiplayer
whereas in like battlefield 3 like the
tank physics were completely different
oh yeah so you basically were training
people to play the game the wrong way
when they got into multiplayer so
overall I'm really happy with what we've
seen so far I'm actually way into
battlefield hardline being delayed to
make it better I've seen a lot of betas
where they had problems and they like
didn't delay it and it was exactly what
we thought it was gonna be so yeah I
think I agree I I was I know that you've
been looking forward to this I've been
very lukewarm and trepidatious because
if I don't feel for especially but
today's today's new footage kind of
makes me feel a lot more positive
actually a little bit excited